bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors ce procès en
destitution qui doit durer deux semaines
et il a peu de chances d'aboutir puisque
c'est un sénat acquis à la cause de
donald trump est ce que réellement
donald trump n'a rien à craindre
oui réellement de notre rédaction
on en est sûr puisque après cette
première journée de procédures ou plutôt
de vote sur les procédures au sénat on a
vu que le vote se faisait sur une ligne
partisane 47 démocrates contre 53
républicain il ne manquait pas une voix
un appel sur l'ensemble des motions et
effectivement on voit bien que dans les
deux camps ne s'écoute pas le sénat a
l'intention de faire ces règles comme il
l'entend comme dit mitch mcconnell alors
que les démocrates ne veulent poursuivre
leur instruction qui a commencé à la
chan alors désormais ne sont plus à la
chan mais son senna doit donc deux chocs
de culture presque qui s'affrontent dans
ce procès on imagine que les démocrates
en une stratégie est ce que cette
impeachment va a révélé selon vous de
nouveaux éléments à charge contre le
président américain dont il va y avoir
aucun nouvel élément à charge parce que
les sénateurs vont et ont déjà voté pour
exclure tout nouveau document donc ce
sont les mêmes documents qui vont être
représentés à nouveau quand ils posent
problème comme il l'avait posée au à la
chambre ce sera à huis clos exactement
comme à la chambre et il n'y aura donc
rien qui va jaillir dans l'escarcelle
pour assouvir la tente du public
certainement on va donc avoir un bis
repetita de l'instruction de la chambre
et la stratégie démocrate
la stratégie démocrate elle a été très
bien décrit par votre correspondante 1
il s'agit d'une part effectivement
d'abîmer l'image de donald trump le plus
possible puisque la campagne d'influencé
qu'il est actuellement sur une île à la
baraka il faut le dire l'économie se
porte très bien ont ils entendu à davos
ir triomphe en expliquant que les états
unis sont aujourd'hui la plus forte
économie du monde et c'est donc le
président de la plus forte économie du
monde qui se représente au suffrage et
si les démocrates ne peuvent le faire
chuter d'une manière ou d'une autre ils
vont pas s'en priver
et la campagne la future campagne
présidentielle qui va s'annoncer
est ce que justement elle peut être
entachée par cette procédure de
destitution
figurez-vous je ne le crois pas je ne
crois pas parce que ok ou loue depuis le
9 novembre 2016 c'est à dire que le mot
destitution est revenue 350 fois dans la
vie politique est aujourd'hui les
électeurs américains s'en sont lassés il
n'écoute plus en réalité ce qui se passe
du côté de washington et de la maison
blanche
ils ne pensent plus forcément que leur
président a fait quelque chose de mal
dans cette affaire là qui d'ailleurs
affaire qui s'est compliqué et comme
elle s'est beaucoup compliqué
aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens n'écoutent
plus et ne la comprennent pas donc tout
ça ça ne va pas avoir énormément de
conséquences dans la campagne qui va
venir
c'est pour cela que donald trump
finalement il est parti à davos - ya
beaucoup d'enjeu a on le sait économique
mais il est parti finalement à davos
avec l'esprit tranquille c'est le
sentiment qu'il a donné en tout cas il
ya peut-être beaucoup d'anges économique
mais souvenez-vous que l'année dernière
il n'y était pas il y avait un chef d'al
il avait compris que c'était un moment
grâce pour l'amérique il était resté à
washington cette fois ci ils auraient pu
faire la même chose en expliquant que la
constitution était aujourd'hui en péril
ou en tout cas elle était mise à
l'épreuve puisqu'il est en procès quand
même contre le président des états unis
il aurait pu rester à washington ne
serait ce que pour faire une montre un
visage peuple ce qu'il n'a pas fait il a
fait exactement le contraire il est allé
à davos triomphant en expliquant que
tout cela c'est une péripétie ce qui a
tendance il faut le dire à rendre assez
futile ce qui se passe à la chambre dans
la tête de beaucoup de bombes jean eric
branaa un président sous le coup d'une
procédure de destitution peut-il
remporter la mise pour un second mandat
présidentiel
eh bien figurez vous que c'est ce qu'on
va découvrez le
le 3 novembre prochain puisque ça n'est
jamais arrivé les deux précédents
présidents qui ont fait face à la
destitution était en fin de mandat des
deuxièmes banda pour bill clinton donc
c'est c'est vraiment une vraie nouveauté
historique et maintenant c'est ouvert
donc on va voir ce soir une première si
donald trump ayant été impeach remporté
effectivement l'élection suivante ce qui
lui donnerait raison
par la suite merci beaucoup jean eric
branaa pour cet éclairage rappelle que
vous êtes un spécialiste des états unis
est maître de conférences à paris assas